please welcome molly burnham
[Applause]
hi molly hi i'm freaking out how are you
doing i am so
good how are you
this is like a weird dream though right
we're sitting here drew's getting a
tattoo
molly's here i know this is so fun i
mean
molly we were so excited to do the news
with you because
you know your show like really shows the
power of friendship and i know that
you've become
so close with hillary duff over the
years
and the thing that other than my
daughters has meant the most to me
in my life is my friendship same tell me
about your relationship with hillary and
your history
and your future you know i had just
graduated from the yale school of drama
when i got on this show i had i had
no idea what i was doing and i was so
stressed out and wanted to make sure
everything was perfect
um and one day on set she was like just
chill you're funny
and like we love you just be a little be
a little less stressed out because it's
kind of stressful and that kind of
realness
it's really good advice and i carry it
on every set
i go to i carry it into my work and that
she we just kind of became
fast friends because she saw through my
bs and she was like you don't need it
actually
you'll be lighter without it and that
carries
through into our friendship i mean she's
the best friend i have would you mind
doing a couple new stories with us
i can't wait to do a news story okay
good just checking in on drew how are
you feeling over there
i just got reminded not to move okay
understood
all right well uh molly our first story
is about someone near and dear to your
heart
may hillary duff's one month old baby
yo look at this yahoo life reports that
hillary brought mae to beat mandy
moore's newborn gus
and they had a blast and i know that you
and hillary of course you're you're
besties from younger and but there's an
interesting story you went to go
help with baby may and ended up staying
for what like a month
a month you went to go home what is that
like you did she just needed your help
and you were there
actually um i we weren't sure when she
was going to be born
may not hillary we knew that yeah and i
so i planned to go out to la for vaguely
a month
and to see when the baby came and i mean
this is her third so i really wanted to
be an extra set of hands yeah
and i'm her other daughter's godmother
so i was just
i mean i got to do bath time and bedtime
and then wake up time
is the best they're so tender in the
mornings when they wake up come on
how did it feel to hold that little tiny
baby
she is edible and she was so
so so so so cuddly too she loved to be
held
and bank banks was like that too really
hillary makes really cuddly people oh
and i i feel like i'm so lucky i'm like
a parent in training she's taught me and
my partner hannah
how to be she's such a good mother
may i ask um because i was so scared
with olive
and then i was a bit calmer with frankie
what is hilary like
with her second and third is she
different is she
you know what's she like as a mom um i
hope she doesn't get mad at me for
saying this but she
um you know how parents by the one month
old two month old like
the the blankets that you put the baby
on and take pictures of uh-huh
she didn't have one for may and so she
got one for the day after may turned a
month old she was like it's a third kid
thing
[Laughter]
just at that point you're like right i'd
love for you to read the next story
molly because i think that
i really want to hear from you and ross
what you guys think of this
all right here we go okay next up i'm
planning
my wedding right now and ron
i know you are too yes we're both in
recently engaged recently queer engaged
yeah you didn't
think dog herself so i want to take on
this new wedding trend
okay all right it is the who what where
reports
second looks are becoming a thing for
bridesmaids and this basically means
that your bridesmaids will wear the
matchy matchy look to the ceremony but
then
at the reception they can change into
whatever they want yes what do we think
i love this idea because weddings are so
formal
and i hate the idea of people coming
together and being uncomfortable
all day long like sure show up in heels
but then when it's time for the
reception can we all just agree to be an
elastic
is that all right yes yes absolutely no
buttons no buttons i just
unzipped the zipper from my skirt
because ryan told me she wanted me relax
i was like then i need to unzip before
we go
molly i would love for you to tell us
about your new film milk water
um i think the story line is beautiful
significant and i'm really excited that
it's becoming
more of a common acceptable beautiful
conversation
out in the world will you please tell us
about it i would love to
um i made this film it's the first film
that i'm
leading which is really exciting um and
it's about how difficult it is to start
queer families
uh i play a really lost millennial
who befriends an older gay man at a drag
bar
and um i can't relate i'm sure you can't
relate yeah
so you don't know anything about this so
she befriends this drag queen and offers
to be his surrogate kind of the night
that she meets him
and um it explores boundaries and
boundarylessness
and just how um vulnerable it is
to rely on a surrogate for starting your
family
and my you know my partner and i are
about to go on the
marriage journey and the kids journey
and it's it's hard when you're two women
or two men
and or when you're as this film depicts
a single gay man surrogacy i think is
a very important conversation do you
guys want to have
kids we do we're so
i mean honestly i think hannah and i
were like cosplaying at hillary's house
i'd be like you run the bath i'll go
take her
i'll get her you know i'll get some of
the clothes off yeah make sure the
bubbles are in
make sure it's not too hot and handy
like got it you look hot and i was like
yes we like had so much fun
well thank you molly um i am
so honored that you came to the desk
today it was so nice to talk about
family friendship surrogacy
you know life really what a the real
stuff
what a menu and milk water is on demand
on may 21st